pernod benedetti rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire bonsoir
arnaud benedetti alors on a vu qu
emmanuel mais cros avait redorée un
petit peu son blason au niveau de la
confiance lors de son dernier discours
cette conférence de presse d'edouard
philippe est ce qu'elle est et est de
nature selon vous a redonné confiance en
français et à rassurer ou alors rajouter
plutôt de la confusion
s'ils voulaient c'était une conférence
de presse qu'il ressemblait plutôt un
rapport d'étape où le premier ministre
est venu comme l'a rappelé votre
éditorialistes faire le service après
vente du président de la république
après son allocution de lundi dernier on
avait un premier ministre qui à force de
powerpoint le diagramme deux chiffres
s'est efforcé d'oeuvrer contextualiser
la situation de donner quelques signes
d'espoir en expliquant ce chiffre à
l'appui que la tension sur l'offre de
soins et est aujourd'hui le moindre même
si elle restait forte qu'elle ne l'avait
été il ya encore quelques jours mais
finalement cette conférence de presse a
répondu à très peu de questions
concernant notamment l'objectif qu'a
fixé président de la république
c'est-à-dire l'objectif de sortie
progressive du confinement à partir du
11 mai on reste aujourd'hui avec
plusieurs angles morts concernant les
moyens sanitaires c'est à dire les
masques concernant les tests concernant
la façon dont le retour des enfants va
éventuellement s'opérer dans les écoles
sur tous ces sujets on voit bien que on
est disons dans une opération de work in
progress c'est à dire que on apprend en
marchant mais les solutions concrètes ne
sont pas encore en tout cas apparu on a
justement le sentiment que les français
se posent davantage encore de questions
sur ce déconfinement va-t-il être bien
préparé suffisant est il crédible
au 11 mai moins que jamais on a on a la
réponse finalement vous voulez le
président de la république à annoncer
une date le 11 mai qu'il faut
aujourd'hui absolument tenir ne serait
ce que symboliquement mais une grande
partie de l'opinion et la majorité de
nos compatriotes ont vraisemblablement
compris après avoir entendu le premier
ministre hier même s'il avait vraiment
compris l'umci de la première allocution
du président de la république et les
reprises ensuite de ces différents
ministres suite à cette allocution que
ceux des confinement se ferait de
manière très étroite et très progressive
mais il y a deux éléments qui sont
aujourd'hui extrêmement important pour
l'exécutif en france dans cette crise et
qui explique vincent dans cette volonté
de tenir un discours sur le dic de le
déconfinement ce sont d'abord les
paramètres économiques car on sait que
aujourd'hui la situation économique et
la situation sociale suite à cette crise
sanitaire sera pour le moins tendues et
puis il ya aussi la comparaison que l'on
fait avec un certain nombre d'états
voisins qui ont donné le sentiment et
pas seulement donné le sentiment
récurrent mais sans en mieux maîtriser
la propagation de l'épidémie et qui ont
déjà opéré une première étape dans le
déconfinement qu'il s'agisse par exemple
d amour ou des autrichiens comment
explique-t-on comment expliquez vous ce
manque d'anticipation de la part du
gouvernement français alors que vous le
soulignez les voisins européens semblent
mieux parer cette situation à commencer
par le voisin allemand écoutez je pense
que il ya d'abord un phénomène qui
dépasse même le cadre du seul mandat d'
emmanuel macron c'est à dire que on a
connu depuis un certain nombre d'années
voire de décennies processus de
désarmement sanitaires à travers des
logiques comptables dans l'hôpital
public et au niveau d'un certain nombre
d'opérateurs sanitaires donc cet
exécutif a une part de responsabilité
mais une part de responsabilité qui sa
stricte dans un mouvement qui est
beaucoup plus plus large
ensuite il ya eu dès le départ une
sous-estimation évidente delà de la
menace virale je rappelle que la
ministre de la santé madame buzet le 24
janvier nous annoncer que ce virus selon
toute vraisemblance avait peu de chances
d'accoster sur les rives de l'europe
donc 7,7 cette faiblesse dans
l'anticipation a vraisemblablement nuit
au bon démarrage de la gestion de crise
aujourd'hui on attend emmanuel macron
évidemment sur le déconfinement mais il
a déjà esquissé la presse jean-yves le
drian ni ma crainte c'est que le monde
après ressemble au monde d'avant mais en
pire vous partager cette inquiétude de
jean yves le drian
je crois que en tout cas le président de
la république est soumis à la remise en
question de ce qu'a été sa promesse
politique en 2017 et ce qui a été
d'ailleurs l'exercice de son mandat
depuis 2010 est c'est à dire cette idée
que il fallait d'une certaine manière à
marche forcée adapter le pays aux
standards d'une globalisation à laquelle
il ne s'était pas adaptées depuis
finalement de longues décennies on l'a
la crise que nous traversons l'épreuve
sanitaires que nous traversons resser
apparaître un certain nombre de notions
qui étaient des notions qu'ils n'étaient
plus en tout cas porté par les élites
dirigeantes de ce pays il s'agit de la
question de la frontière la question de
la souveraineté la question du contrôle
la question du maîtrise de la maîtrise
et le la promesse électorale des manuels
macron la promesse politique d' emmanuel
macron est profondément aujourd'hui
collisionner par cette épreuve qui amène
in fine l ensemble des dirigeants
occidentaux à se reposer la question sur
leur propre modèle économique
merci beaucoup arnaud benedetti
rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire d'avoir été
avec nous